de toute façon je vous fait écouter
quelque chose on vient tout de suite
après ok je suis assez indécis parce que
je trouve que ce qui a été dit jusqu'à
date n'y a rien qui me correspond je
convaincu du npd capable de faire aussi
bien que des conservateurs à tête
dégringolé par rapport au niqab la
saveur la map est content
votre but sauf que j'imagine que les
sondages influence toujours un peu la
population mais j'espère qu'ils vont
être capables
une décision alors les sondages voulez
vous faire plaisir en début de panels on
va mon va se on va montrer un tableau si
vous le voulez bien intentions de vote
au canada d'abord c'est un abacus c'est
sorti aujourd'hui 30 2% conservateurs 29
pour les libéraux et 27 pour le npd une
chute pour le npd
mais vous allez voir le prochain le
prochain tableau ça c'est au québec npd
30 pour cent d'appuis toujours en
première place mais regarder à côté une
baisse de 17% dont jade vous entends le
libéro 24% en hausse une forte hausse
pour les conservateurs au québec selon
ce sondage 21 % et le bloc est à 20 pour
ça bien sûr qu'on peut pas prendre les
chiffres au pied de la lettre c'est
peut-être pas moins 17
je pense qu'on va tous entendre quelque
chose qui se passe pour le npd
ralentissement constant depuis plusieurs
semaines et là une dégringolade de
michel oui c'est clair n'importe quel
candidat npd au québec va vous le dire
quand ils vont porte le centre il ya un
effet ni câble il ya aussi un autre fait
monsieur walker s'est fait attaquer très
durement dix ans il disait pas la même
chose en français et en anglais y a pas
répondu à ces attaques là elles vont
faire mal aussi
cela dit 17.7 une hémorragie là c'est
pire que ce que le bloc perdait quand
est arrivée la vague orange de 4 à
remarquer que ce que la vague donne la
vague peu leurs preuves mais ça
m'étonnerait que ça soit aussi fort que
soi cela dit la perte actuellement
depuis au npd est évidente elle est
palpable au québec
est ce que mes skis ce qui me chicote un
peu dans le sondage abacus c'est que ça
ça n'irait aux conservateurs alors déjà
irène pedic essentiellement pour battre
un procès on s'attendrait chez apple ça
j'ai de la misère à voir comment on peut
faire ce pas là emmanuel ouais c'est ça
parce qu'au delà des chiffres bien
précis il ya une tendance au québec et
ailleurs en ontario également le npd
avec la folie à deux semaines oui le [ __ ]
avait un plafond ni plafonne en réalité
presque depuis le début de la campagne
l'heure ralentis
il faut comprendre et le ou les chiffres
du québec font très mal ou reste de la
campagne du npd ailleurs au pays ce à
deux égards depuis le début de la
campagne
on disait quand le npd semblait au ocana
dans des fours prendre avec des
pincettes
les chiffres nationaux sont nourris par
la force du npd au québec mais là c'est
l'effet inverse
mais le problème c'est dans tous les
gros rassemblement tout le message une
partie du message du npd en faveur du
changement c'est de dire aux électeurs
ontariens aux électeurs de la colme brut
britannique
regardez on est au gang le québec avec
le québec et vous on peut renverser un
peu si monsieur mulcair perd la capacité
de faire ce plaidoyer la de citer le
québec en exemple sa mine d'une certaine
façon sa force de changement sa force de
conviction auprès de ses électeurs la
moyen autre chiffre qui m'a surpris et
que j'ai remarqué dans ce sondage lancé
à bacchus à demander aux gens ce qu'ils
veulent absolument le changement pour
qu'ils votent il est même au sein de ce
bassin d'électeurs là à l'échelle
nationale mais npd a perdu 10 points et
sont maintenant absolument à égalité
statistique avec le parti libéral
voilà donc alex on se posait la question
début de cette campagne qui va s'emparer
du thème du changement il va aller
jusqu'au 19 octobre contre monsieur un
peu et la stabilité le statu quo entre
guillemets hélas assez batailler un peu
là les libéraux semblent eux en
croissance constante
ouais c'est ce qui est spécial c'est
qu'en fait il ya plusieurs courses à
travers le pays paie autant le npd les
chiffres nationaux étaient dopés par le
québec
évidemment comme une dégringolade au
québec en raison essentiellement du
débat sur le niqab depuis deux jours qui
profite aux conservateurs beaucoup
autant les libéraux leurs chiffres
nationaux sont beaucoup dopé notamment
par l'atlantique et l'ontario où ils
font plutôt bien alors qu'au québec il
ya pas eu énormément de changements
depuis le début de la campagne en
colombie-britannique non plus
certainement pas dans les prairies donc
on se retrouve avec une multitude de
courses régionales qui influence les
chiffres nationaux puis dès qu'une
province bouche pour une raison ou une
autre dans le cas du québec c'est le
niqab ou sa frappe clairement beaucoup
plus fort ici comme controverse
qu'ailleurs au pays
mais là ça arrivait lui ça fait rêver
lui toute la
la dynamique pour ceux qui veulent un
vote anciens pros pour ceux qui veulent
du changement avait requis on se
coalisent ce qu'est ce que les libéraux
est ce que c'est le npd on regarde les
sondages nationaux puis c'est ce qu'est
une influence en bout de pc qui vont en
avoir une c'est la fin du scrutin je
vous donne 50 chacun est ce que vraiment
vraiment vous croyez que c'est le niqab
qui a pu faire changer touchant michel
c'est le niqab et les attaques de visage
à deux faces latérales en est comme ça
contre monsieur walker s'éclate le niqab
en effet est-ce qu'il ya une fête
durable ça c'est pas sûr souvenez vous
la chambre des valeurs manuel la manic
un niqab
oui mais aussi cette accusation de
double discours moi j'ajouterais au
québec
la plateforme électorale du npd dans une
longue campagne les gens finissent par
les regarder en entendent parler
critiquer juste à être d'autant qu'on
veut mais je pense que tout le monde y
écouter les bassa puis un plan qui veut
dépenser l'argent ce qui veut relancer
l'économie sogeclair d'un côté monsieur
mulcair ce message plus diffus ou sa
promesse phare celle des garderies très
peu d'écho ici finalement et qu'on dit
les gens veulent du changement il faut
que leurs vis à vis mieux mais le npd
peine à leur faire la preuve qu au
lendemain d'une élection néo démocrates
il va y avoir des changements concrets
dans la vie des gens malek jeu de la
difficulté à croire que disent ils du 9
octobre les gens qui veulent du
changement ils sont très nombreux au
québec le dernier sondage la noce montré
que 75 % des québécois voulaient un
changement de gouvernement tahoua j'ai
de la misère à croire que pour le seul
code du niqab
les gens vont soudainement se mettent à
voter conservateur je pense que le npd a
le temps de redresser la situation
je pense que le
les mêmes les libéraux québec qui font
une campagne tout à fait potable
pourrait aussi en profiter
éventuellement alors à ce que c'est un
moment dans la campagne mon impression
c'est que c'est un moment puis qu'on va
finalement leur parler d'économie
reparler d'affaires étrangères a parlé
d'autre chose
est-ce que ça va être trop tarder son
verrou affaires étrangères justement il
ya débat ce soir ce qu'ils en pensent
aussi à un six pack c'est pas que le
diffuse des banques que sur la politique
étrangère
je vous ai préparé deux trois
informations
l'opinion des canadiens sur la politique
étrangère du canada approuve la mission
militaire canadienne contre le groupe
etat islamique 61 % et 39 %
désapprouvent la mission autre question
l'opinion sur la politique étrangère
crois que la principale priorité de la
politique étrangère canada devrait être
de belles bâtir de meilleurs liens
commerciaux que les autres nations 57
pour ça parce qu'on a un autre tableau
wi fi nalement crois que la réputation
internationale du canada s'est dégradé
depuis dix ans 41% et 21 que s'est
améliorée c'est intéressant qui est un
débat sur la politique étrangère ce soit
parce qu'il ya des enjeux réels et qui
sont un facteur cette fois-ci mme chan
oui c'est un facteur mais c'est pas un
facteur aussi grand que l'économie ou
des choses comme ça mais il ya des liens
qui se font qu'il ne se faisait pas
avant
par exemple environnement et affaires
étrangères la conférence de paris
c'est l'environnement c'est plus quelque
chose qu'on décide seul dans sa cour de
s'occuper de la pollution des eaux et de
d'une usine ou d'une raffinerie
il ya donc on voit que le monde est
globalisée et que la politique étrangère
touche beaucoup de choses cela dit c'est
quand même pas là qu'est la question de
l'isoloir argument politique canadienne
dans un débat comme celui là d'ailleurs
c'est plus dangereux de perdre des
points parce qu'on fait une erreur gens
dire azerbaïdjan au lieu d' afghanistan
opus souvenir du nom de monsieur poutine
ça ça fait très mal alors sur un superbe
débat de politique étrangère je crois
que ça fait bouger liant les sondages le
lendemain avec emmanuel il ya des
positions bien tranchées sur la lutte
conte et islamique entre autres monsieur
mulcair aimé monsieur trudeau sont
contre les la portion des bombardements
lie à l'oeil un clivage la manuelle ya
un clivage est ce qu'on voit aussi dans
ce sondage angus reid c'est une bonne
part de l'électorat néo démarre
tous les bureaux qui sont pas
nécessairement d'accord avec leur chef
sur cet enjeu des frappes contre le
groupe armé est ta islamique je vous
dirais que pour les deux chefs temps
monsieur mulcair que monsieur trudeau
l'objectif de ce débat là c'est d'une
part de passer au travers comme disait
michel s'enfarger sans faire de gaffe
c'est le genre d'enjeu ou d'une part et
donc ils veulent remplacer le premier
ministre une question de prestance de
crédibilité je suis michael veut miser
convaincre canadien foyer je suis un
premier ministre tout près en attente
dresse une stratégie de monter les
attentes à l'égard de monsieur mulcair
on va voir ce que ça donnait comme
monsieur trudeau encore ici présents
dans un débat où les attentes sont pas
immensément autres le but pour lui c'est
vraiment de montrer peut-être de
rassurer les gens sur le fait qu'
capable d'avoir non pas des phrases des
clips des lignes là dessus mais à cette
substance pour débattre adéquatement de
ces enjeux là parce que pendant deux
heures là quand même où exactement
l'idéal est que je vous donne 20
secondes l'idée c'est d'avoir l'air
premier ministre quoi ouais et le
premier ministre sortant toujours un
avantage dans ce type de débat là parce
que lui il a paradé ou à côté des chefs
d'état dans le g7 dans le j-20 il ya
déjà eu donc plusieurs années
d'expérience sur la scène internationale
qui est pas nécessairement une scène
internationale facile avec les mikea
comprendre s'est rendu très complexes
ont levé avec la crise des migrants
ciric s'est invitée dans la campagne
électorale
mais de multiples facettes et pour un
chef de l'opposition la voix l'air à la
hauteur du premier ministre sortant qui
a eu cette expérience c'est pas évident
merci en même temps justin trudeau a
beaucoup de travail à faire parce que
lorsque savez comment c'est difficile
pour lui c'était au tour justement des
bombardements cyril c'est tout le temps
qu'on a merci à vous trois à très
bientôt a prévenu la meilleure pour les
comptes a salué